[Music]
no drama on CBS tonight just angels the
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show here's
this evening but I got to tell you it
wasn't all wings and catwalks in
Shanghai things actually got a little
physical when I joined two of the ladies
for some martial arts we really wanted
to like you know embrace how they work
out and like learn new things so we
thought coming code would be such a fun
way to do it sure they're angels but
jasmine and Josephine are also BFFs who
do everything together they even have
their own joint Instagram account where
they post all their workouts
chica run me read Lina can't get rid of
her she lives right next door and then
we tell my name is Jim she's there
tonight as we'll be friends with her
we have our own little nickname we're
chocha how are those workouts and who
motivate - she definitely motivates me
because she is like a beast in the gym
it's very competitive you are you don't
even take break from the gym like you'd
go from set to set and I'm like walking
the runway as a dream come true for
these best friends I've did paragliding
one time and I think this is more crazy
this is crazier than gonna go by
airplane Jasmine even rock the Fantasy
Bra last year what happens to the
Fantasy Bra after you where they take it
apart but for Josephine there's one
thing more valuable as an angel you get
this special ring and is that like a
little lucky term they handed it to me
when you become an angel so they it's
that you're like honored to wear those
they're more rare than Super Bowl rings
[Music]
you